From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is June the 30th 2016 and we are in Santa Rosa, California.
And this is David Klein from the History Department at Virginia Tech.
And also working with UNC, that is the Southern oral history program from the University of North Carolina,
on the Civil Rights History Project, which is a project of the Library of Congress,
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Behind the camera today we have John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
We're also joined today in the room by Guha Shankar of the Library of Congress.
And we have distinct pleasure of interviewing Big Man,
who is a veteran of the Black Panther Party.
And I'll ask you if you could introduce yourself,
and only time I'll coach you a complete sentence, I am, or my name is, and your name, and where you were born and when.
Okay.
Ready?
Okay, my name is Elbert "Big Man" Howard.
And I'm from Santa, New York, Tennessee, a native of Santa, New York, Tennessee,
but a long time resident of California, Northern California specifically.
And I wound up in Northern California after military service,
been in four years in the Air Force, and they decided to discharge me,
or I decided I wanted to be discharged in California because I loved it here, I loved the people.
And been a young man, I'm trying to find my way.
And so I ventured into Oakland, and started to sort of my, I guess, formal education,
or what I wanted out of education in Oakland and Merritt College.
Can I ask you first just a little bit about your childhood,
so you were born in Tennessee in one year?
1938.
And can you tell us a little bit about your family there, and growing up in the South?
Yeah, well, growing up, I don't know if it was typical or not,
but my father died, I never knew him.
All I knew was my mother, and aunts and cousins.
And I think that I was pretty much raised up as an only son by women", the aunts, my mother's sisters.
And then my cousins were, I guess you could say, my brothers and sisters really.
And I attended school and in high school.
And that sort of thing.
And all the schools were segregated schools at the time.
Right.
And I think long about 1954, they began to talk about integrating schools.
And I heard about that.
I told myself I have no problem going to school with white kids because I have my own set of friends
and living in my own set of society.
So I'm not up for that, but if it happens, it happens.
But I had teachers who I thought were concerned about me, who tried to teach me things that I needed to know to survive in a hostile world.
So, you know, I had no problem about wanting to integrate anything like that.
And I went through to the 11th grade.
And my mother being a single parent and everything.
I got to growing up and becoming an adult.
I figured one of the best ways for me to help support her and to develop myself was to join the military.
The air force after conversing with a lot of my friends who have been through basic training and all of that and come back.
And I picked their brains as to what it was all about.
And that's where I made my selection to choose the air force to go.
And what year was that?
That was when I was doing it in 1956.
I think I went there a few years after the Korean War.
Yeah, I missed that one.
Had you talked to other veterans who had been in that war or came back?
I had some relatives that had been to war and stuff like that.
And you know, the guys made a stay away from the army one day.
Why is that?
Because the army was the cattle pulled to going into combat and all that sort of thing.
And what I could find out about the air force is like you go in, you go through your basic training and everything.
And after that it was like a job.
You know, you went to work, you did what you were told.
And you had three meals a day at this place to live.
And you had freedom to explore the places that they sent you to.
So I felt very fortunate to be sent to Europe.
And I got to know Paris and Stockholm and cope in the hay again.
I visited all those places and met different people.
And to me it was a revelation.
And I opened into meet people of other culture.
And I realized that even though the people were called scathing or white, if you want to give it a color, they were very different than the white said I had a great fear of in the south that I grew up with.
So that was a revelation and a learning experience.
And to immerse myself and learn about their cultures, to learn how to drink wine and go to art museums and be talk stuff.
And you know, that was a good part of maturity, and maturing to me.
What about racial dynamics in the air force itself and seeing basic training but then when you got to Europe?
Well, it had it little nuances of segregation and even in France, which is a different environment.
And you had blacks hanging together because I don't know, our cultural similarities or whatever.
And you got along with the whites for the game.
When it comes to stuff like economics, when it comes to promotions and stuff like that, you looked over, screwed over.
You just let it go by and enjoy yourself.
And learn what you wanted to learn and survive.
And to a great extent be happy without having to look over your show all the time.
Did you go in thinking that you would make a career of it or was this just a way out of where you were?
At the time, I thought it was kind of a way out to learn something different at the same time, to support my mother and a lot of it.
And so I knew I just got to check every month and I had food and shelter and everything for myself.
And you know, I think to me it was a pretty good deal.
I just had to put up with whatever I had to put up with.
And it wasn't all that strange.
It was abide by the rules and the routines and what you were told.
As long as you were there in the camp or whatever.
When you got your free time you had a chance to get out and explore and pretty much have a good time.
You know, go to jazz clubs and converse with jazz musicians who had left the US for the freedom of Europe to be able to practice their art and so forth.
And you know, it became an adventure for me.
Did you already have a love for jazz when you went over or did that develop in your own?
I grew up, you know, the process of development from listening to the spirituals to old-time blues to R&B when that came in the focus.
And B-bop had come along. My brain was a progression.
You know, right on up until today, you know, look for the new sound and you know, adapt to it.
So you ended up after Europe went back to the United States in California?
Yeah.
And I can say I was still in the service on the air base in New Orleans, California.
It's a good thing.
And used to go into town in Oakland.
And that's why I met a lot of people.
And you know, the very rich culture, you had blues and jazz and great soul food and friendly people.
And they took me under their wings, sort of speak, as a young trooper, and showed me around and stuff like that.
And I enjoyed that.
So when I got my discharge, I decided to take it here in Northern California and hang out in Oakland.
You know, and not really having any focus. That's what I really wanted to do.
I looked for a job at that time. It was really hard to come by.
Pretty much as you're out today. But I had a resource and education benefits from the Air Force.
So I decided to enter into City College in Oakland and draw my GI bill.
It's up to to sustain me, you know, until I found some type of employment and all that.
And in the meantime, I began to study black history and stuff like that.
And I didn't have any real academic ambitions.
But I always thought that I wanted to be able to be able to write and express myself clearly.
So I took some courses in writing and stuff like that in school to try to develop writing skills, nothing professional just my own.
And I wanted to convey something to be able to do it.
And black history had been part of your schooling at all in Tennessee?
No. No. At that time, it was not even thought of.
So this was new material for you in some ways.
At Enrolling in Merritt College, I began to associate with other students who had, you know, similar interests.
And that's where I met Bobby Seale and Huey Newton.
And we used to, after our classes, with how we were in the rap sessions and talk about these things and talk about ways of dealing with them.
Because we had repression going on in Oakland police repression.
And people getting killed by cops every week.
And we would kick around ways of dealing with that, you know, try to figure out a different way of approaching it as opposed to the civil rights and the non-violence and all that sort of stuff.
Because we knew what that was about. But we were trying to develop a new approach, you know, something progressive and revolutionary, if you will.
And so, you know, Bobby Seale and I want you to meet Huey.
And we were thinking of starting a new organization.
And they started to develop the 10 point platform and program, which was, you know, the mandate, you know, if you will, that would differentiate us from other organizations.
Because they had other organizations that dealt with culture, you know, Swahili camps and learning language and stuff like that.
And we were more interested in trying to deal with combating the yields in the community on progressive and revolutionary level.
So what were some of the issues at the base of the 10 point platform?
We were on freedom. We want the power to determine our destiny, which is number one on the list.
And we felt we were occupied by police forces, you know, doing the bidding of the rich politicians.
So we began to study things like the writings of Che Guevara and Mao Zedong, Kwame Nkrumah Malcolm X and all the revolutionary people around the world.
And we started to cherry pick some of their philosophies and ways of thinking and apply it to what we wanted to do.
We fully realized that we were not in China, we were not in Cuba. And we couldn't emulate anything that those people did.
But we had to come up with our own approach utilizing what we could from these great people, you know.
And that's where we got a lot of our philosophy from.
Could I ask you to tell me just a little bit more about young Bobby Seale and young Huey Newton?
Well, they were like when you first met and started hanging out with these guys.
Well, with Bobby, I hung more with him than with Huey. He was always, you know, in and out sort of speak.
But, you know, he was, to me, very knowledgeable because he about the justice system because he had been through it.
And whenever I had a case or some problem with the police, I could usually go to here and say, you know, I said I approached this and going to court and stuff like that.
So he knew, you know, how I should do that.
And so I got somebody to lie to him. But we never hung together except for having meetings as the organization began to come together and grow, you know.
Some more than then. But Bobby, to me, was had a great skill for organizing, you know.
And he had great ideas. And at the time, early on, a lot of them seemed very far fixed to me.
But I've always been a listener and try to internalize what I'm hearing, you know.
And put it in the locker for later references.
But we would get together with other kids on campus and we'd sit down and we would, you know, go back and forth about approaches and ways of solving problems and so forth.
And in the meantime, Bobby said we were starting a new organization and then they began to work on that 10-point platform program and reach it out, OK.
Who was an agent who pretty much grew up after he got out of that damn camp that they put his family in.
He began to live in the associate with the other poor and oppressed people in Oakland. I mean, black people.
So, you know, he used to hang and he worked with Bobby on that 10-point platform program.
And, you know, it just started to come together. Our ideas and so forth. And we began to talk more and more with more and more people.
And they said, yeah, you know, I can relate to these ideas and so forth.
What do we do next, you know. And it came together like pretty much like that.
Was there, I think, a particular incident with the police that sort of pushed you towards the group a little bit more?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Tell us about that.
Because as I said, I enjoyed going out to Oakland to the Blues and Jazz clubs and so forth.
And one night I was out at a club that Don Barksdale's was, we got to run a club with black ex-Baskabalt player.
And I think it was a little wrong when he was first coming on and getting popular.
Went out to see his show and me and my date and when it was over, we were leaving.
And it was drizzling outside. So I told my date wait here.
I'm going to go and get my vehicle on and I'll come back and pick it right in front of the club.
So I'll pull up in front of the club waiting for her to come out and the cops come up and start writing tickets.
Well, it wrote me a ticket and I looked at behind me and they didn't write the guy behind me one and the person they hit at me.
And I took offense because I had a brand new red pickup truck.
And I protested, I asked them, you know, why the hell am I getting a ticket and you're in writing these other people in here?
And it says, some smart and I say, well, fuck this, I'm taking off.
So I got my truck and took off and then here comes the game.
It boxed me in and took me in and I picked up to jail.
So from then on, I said, well, you know, I got to get involved with something that combats this kind of crap.
And this is what you were invited to talk about.
You know, I went to court and asked you to advise me and stuff.
And he went to court with me and the judge says, well, something that offended me and something like,
well, he's probably guilty, but I'm going to dismiss it.
In the meantime, the cops are sitting there in the court laughing and shit, you know.
And I got, you know, highly pissed off about that.
Anyway, dismiss the case.
So after that, I left and I took to very angry and I took to driving around in my pickup.
I had a rack put in the back of it and I put a legal shotgun in the back of it.
So I rode around and I'd say, well, you know, I'm as good as somebody red next to it right around like this.
And if I may go confront it, I'm going to defend myself, period.
So, you know, luckily, nothing happened and I didn't have to do that.
I continued to do that.
And, you know, as I was doing the party, I continued to do that.
And you all had researched and were aware that it's perfectly legal, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
And on a way to take Huey home after the court date, I asked him about the legalities of a car and a weapon in the car.
He called me on that.
That's why, you know, I was able to do that.
I knew that it was perfectly legal and it was a 12-gauge shotgun that I purchased.
And, you know, went from there.
So what were some of the first things that you all did?
In terms of work that you did with the party, I think, patrolling the police themselves.
Was that one of the things that you started to do?
Yeah, that happened a little bit later on.
And, you know, we began to get more members and we began to acquire more firearms and stuff.
And, you know, once again, consulting with Huey, he knew the law because he studied law and stuff.
And knew that we could do that legally.
And so we began to do that at night on the weekends when we knew the cops were patrolling our community.
And so we decided that we would get out and patrolling and not to confront them necessarily and engage in any battle.
But to teach people in the community that they had a right, they had rights.
And we would advise people when they would stop by the cops, we'd get out and observe the cops' so-called performing and duty.
And, if we were on the scene, they would not abuse the people.
They became more concerned with these young black people with guns.
And so we advised people that being arrested to go ahead and take their rest, don't resist.
And we're going to follow you down to the courthouse and we're going to bail you out.
And we did that.
And people began to wonder who are these guys?
Why would they be doing that?
And so as a result, they'd drop around to the Panther office to find out more about it.
And we began to gain recruits.
More people to join the party.
That was building up to the organization where people coming in.
And, you know, like I said, the attitude of many young people coming in was that was the emphasis on the Black Panther Party that we were confront cops and be ready to deal with shootouts and so forth.
But when they come in, we'd say, no, we're going to have a political education class.
So it's on set tonight.
If we hadn't scheduled one, give us a phone number and we'll call you and tell you when we're going to hold it.
And we began to teach them revolutionary principles.
And more about what we were about.
And, you know, it went from there.
We weren't in the business of getting anybody killed at that point.
But at the same time, we were determined to defend ourselves no matter what.
And we were determined to get any of our members arrested.
If they went to jail, we were going to do everything we could to get them out as quickly as possible.
And so, of course, that pissed the authorities off too.
You know, if you're not creating animosity or hate, then you're not doing very much against the system of the people that propagate or the repressant.
So for you personally, I mean, alluded to this some and he talked about the incident at the nightclub.
But for you personally, what was driving? What did you want to change?
What was it on the meeting?
Everything.
I taught, you know, I learned a lot from Bobby and stuff in terms of dealing with the yields of the community, you know, like the Denzil Dowell incident in Richmond, where people, I would say, taken notice of the Black Panther Party.
His family, Denzil Dowell's family wasn't getting any answers from the authorities and they were told that they were justified in shooting his kid in the back as he ran and tried to climb a fence.
And his mother knew that and told us that he couldn't possibly jump a fence because he had some injury.
And so we exposed that as a lie.
And we had a demonstration in front of the Richmond Courta House to protest that.
At the same time, we developed, we talked about creating our own news media.
And this one of the first things we did, we remember grab the sheet off, explaining what happened to Denzil Dowell and the lies that his family was told and so forth.
And we took that in the Richmond community and we give it out.
And we asked people to come to a rally.
And you know, we did that and we asked them if you got a quarter or a dime or something going to donate so that we can continue to produce information like this.
And if not, if there was any way, we'd give it to you anyway.
And so that was one of the first organized rallies that we had.
And by the way, we went, we were armed when we went to that rally.
And of course, due to the attention of the police and all that.
But you know, it was part of the growing process.
I think it's like we just get a little drag in.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay.
And you said you were armed at that rally.
So I wanted to ask you if you could tell me just a little bit about the symbolic power of that of the guy.
The symbolic power is that the people in the community saw that.
And they saw that, you know, we weren't rushed to put upon by the authority because we were ready to defend ourselves.
And it essenceed to defend the community if necessary.
So we had a demonstrated determination to do that and the people saw that.
And so that once again drew people to us.
So we began to get more requests for support or whatever, you know.
And you know, whenever we were call our alley, bunches and bunches of people would show up without, you know, without fear and with enthusiasm.
And we were willing to help us and whatever endeavor we were getting into.
You know, like donations for this, that and the other.
We needed an office when we had to pay rent for an office to have a focus in the community where people could relate to.
Rather than, you know, just a roaming group of young men with guns.
So, you know, and I have a place for people to come if they wanted to join, to come and give us a small donation.
So, what have you? So we were in the community. We were visible in the community.
So, you know, it kind of started there, you know.
And that first mimeograph sheet that you had at that rally was at the birth of the Panther News Paper?
Yeah. Yeah. Because, you know, Bob and Seal have said something when we had their alley, said, we need our own organ.
We need our own news facilities.
So, we come up with the thing we were going to mimeograph and I did the text to it.
And Bobby Seale did the graphics with the Panther on it" and all of that.
And, you know, we gave that out and that was really the beginning of our news outlet.
And you were over the newspaper from the beginning of that?
Yeah. Yeah. Somehow, we were, you know, all young and feeling our way as I said.
I guess as I, you know, I have a little bit of things. I've written a little, little corpse for different little radical publications in the community.
And, Bob and Seal said, well, you know, it can be our first editor.
You know, it can be the editor of the paper and, you know, we're going to do some progressive moves and develop this thing.
And, you know, you can be the editor. And I would say, well, I don't know much about being an editor, but that fierce determination to do whatever was necessary.
And, you know, I'll do it. You know, so it started down.
The people write articles and I would read them and do whatever changes ended up saw.
I determined that it would be more readable and so forth when we printed it.
So it kind of started there, you know. And I said, well, okay. I do whatever was necessary.
And, you know, eventually Eldridge Cleaver got out of prison and he was best-selling author with his book, Soul on Ice.
And so we're going to make Eldridge Cleaver the editor perhaps a fine, you know.
And you'll be a minister of information and you'll be the deputy minister of information. Whatever.
So you'd have the minister title after that point of history of information, yeah.
And did that mean giving speeches as well or things like that?
No, that came later. It just was dealing with, you know, putting out information, public information to the form of pamphlets or whatever.
And we needed a steady stream of information going out. So our rights of our people, our rights of our people and other people.
And, you know, we did what we thought was right to put out some cohesive information to the community.
And, but, you know, I never gave too much importance to a title, because it's just wanted to do the work.
I just wanted to make, you know, do some stick of fucking fork in the system.
You know, when some of the speeches came later as, you know, more of the main speakers went to jail.
And all of that, other people had to step up. And I never considered myself a public speaker or anything.
But once again, that old, hard-knows determination said, I was going to do whatever hell it took to advance this vehicle we got going.
So I took a shot at it and turned that all right.
So I keep doing it, keep doing it the more you do it, the more coherent I guess I would.
But that's the way I started.
Okay, we'll back.
So just before we leave the newspaper, how important you think that paper was to the party, both in terms of keeping money coming in, but putting the message out.
Yeah, it was, you know, vital. It was very important. It was vital because we were combating the Oakland Tribune and all the negative shit that they put out about us.
And the San Francisco Chronicle, because they were just printed everything negative that they could.
And so, you know, we knew people in the community about those papers and stuff.
We said, well, you know, we got to put out things that were the truth when some incident goes down or some issues in the community.
We're going to tell the truth about it. And we're going to put it out to the community.
And it was very necessary, you know, and as a party grew across the country and our chapters and stuff begin to develop.
So we would have, we would require that our chapters and branches send us information about incidents in their community that was concerned in their community and also pictures.
And so they would send that stuff in to Central Headquarters and Oakland. And I would look at it and I would, you know, I read it and edit it and make changes or whatever.
And then we would print it in the newspaper and then we would distribute that newspaper back out across the country.
So the people in the community could look at it and see something about what's happening to them in it.
And so that's what made it more popular. And so we began to get, you know, demand weekly.
And it also brought in revenue. You know, a lot of, not in a lot of many because we would sell a paper for 25 cents.
And the party members who didn't have any income go out and sell that paper. They make 15 cents off of it and 10 cents will go into reproduction of the paper.
And it helped fund, you know, activity to the party. So, you know, it was kind of way that that worked.
And they kept people, kept your party members going.
Yeah. And then people, you know, we'd go throughout the community and I'm sure it happened all across the country.
We were being the beauty shops, barbershops, restaurants, wherever and told over here, you know, you should read this paper.
And if you don't have a quarter, we're going to give it to you. You know, here, you need to read this.
And so people began to expect that paper every week. They look for us.
And, you know, that's how it developed. Over 250,000 copies printed every week.
And until a lot of work at the party members would spend 24 hours a day putting it together until we got it out and took it to press.
So, you know, it was definitely vital part of the party's program.
And were you involved in going and laying it out and not getting it printed and that kind of thing?
Yeah. Once again, it was a learning process for me because I never laid out a paper.
We had people that had done it before. Some people, very instrumental like Emory Douglas, who knew how to lay out and definitely produced the artwork for that paper.
So people loved that artwork that he had. Something different every week. Something different and relevant.
So they could look at it and say, you know, I can relate to this.
And so, you know, we learned and many, many, many party members who at skills contributed.
They knew they'd come in and they'd stay up all night and necessarily laying out that paper, you know, getting it right.
And we had trouble getting someone printed because the system told people don't print that paper.
They have comments, anti-American comments, whatever they told people.
So we had a hard time finding somebody to print for a while.
And I went up to Berkeley and talked with Max Scherr, with his name, who ran Max Scherr.
And told him that we were having problems getting our paper printed.
And he said, well, we print our paper on some days of the week.
So after that, bring yourself up here and you can print it here. You can get it done.
So that was a revolutionary step before we were concerned.
And this was a little hippie guy in the community.
And that was, you know, not only helped us get our paper done, but it also provided a core listen and a solidarity with other groups of people.
You know, because we didn't have any foe about him being a hippie or whatever, you know, because he was a progressive guy.
And letting us deal with getting our paper out.
And pretty soon, some of the big printers got wind of how much money was in it and how much we were making.
So they opened up and let us do it. They didn't like it because the FBI told not to do it.
So they knew that we would get on them and print some negative shit about them if they didn't.
So rather than fight that bad publicity and get punched on by the government, they would allow us to do it because it was our,
I don't know, fifth amendment right or whatever.
But, you know, they would tell if people don't go and help them with anything, you know.
And we would be in their office laying out our paper.
But then we had people who wanted to see what we were coming from.
And, you know, a guy would come by and look at the desk.
We were working on an article and say, well, he wouldn't let his boss see him do it.
But he said, want to put that down there.
Look better.
And, you know, so that was progressive, you know.
And so eventually we began to loosen that up and was able to mass produce our paper around.
And we had massive distribution and, you know, we had the fact that the government, because the government told the airlines that they should double charge those to do whatever to make it hard for us to ship our paper.
So it was always some, you know, hardship.
But we overcome it.
We were determined to go around it and stuff.
And we were able to get that paper to people on a weekly basis.
And it began to not only grow nationally, but we began to get people.
From Asia, from Japan, from the African nations, one of that paper.
And so our distribution was really broad.
And, you know, right today, I think if you were found one somewhere, it would cost you over $100.
But, here.
Our friend Bill Hicks got a collection.
Oh, yeah.
Very collection.
Yeah.
You mentioned early on working on the, I just wanted to follow up on this, working on the 10 point program in Richard Aoki Ioke.
What happened to him?
He went, well, at the beginning, he, as we began to develop the organization and began to build solidarity with various groups.
We, you know, began to see we had a large Asian community in Oakland, large Filipino community, as well as the Mexican Americans and Latino community.
So we, things began to really develop.
We've told Richard Aoki why don't you organize the Asian community.
So he began to go up to Berkeley and get involved with the Red Guard Party, I believe, with the organization up there.
And he did, you know, a great job in organizing.
He would report back to us what was going on and stuff.
So that's where, you know, he spent most of his energy as well.
We wanted him where we needed him.
And so, you know, we had, of course, Puerto Rican community, we've been built a solid area with the young lords and, you know, the American Indian Movement.
And he did a great coalition of American oppressed people.
And of course, it raised the anger of the FBI and the established politicians.
But it had to be done, you know.
And Richard Aoki, he was, you know, an ally to the end, you know, I could be somewhere and somebody asked me, you know,
can you get somebody from the party or the exporter member to come down and participate in this and the other.
And I pick up the phone and call Richard Aoki.
And for me, he would always participate and comply, you know, right up until his health store fell.
And we were friends, we participated in, you know, different rallies and gathering and so forth.
And, in fact, when he knew that he was not going to make it in, only he sent me, he gave me an immediate way, he gave me a big pack of slides.
So different things and so forth.
But he was a great member, a great ally and a great guy.
I love Richard Aoki.
He was a great writer here a few years ago, wrote something negative, called him FBI and form something.
I took, the guy that's trying to fill books.
But anyway, I took a show with that and I wrote a blister and critique of it.
And he finally decided he wasn't going to have any benefit from that, so he dropped it.
Rolls and felt with his name.
There's something you're a teacher.
Yeah, I'm getting there.
So, how many more are back?
We'll pick up again.
So, when you were as editor of the paper and then Eldridge came in, so what did you to move on to focus on at that point, your own journey in the party?
And I had a brilliant thing to do.
We had other people stepping in because Eldridge, he was right off from down in, but he became a popular spokesman.
And so, he was always doing this thing.
And so, I had people come in and take responsibility for the paper I had other things to do.
Because as many members started to get busing across the country and going to jail and everything, and I was selected if you will to go and deal with that.
And I began to cross the country going to different penitentiaries and jails to see about party members, to see what their needs, if they had any needs, and also see what the legal situation was.
And see how I could help with their legal defense, talk to lawyers and help lawyers and with things that they needed.
And also talk to people in the particular community, whether these people were in jail, and begin to try to organize defense committees in the community to deal with that person out of jail.
So I was quite busy with that for a long, long time.
My job for a long time, and I go from Denver to New Orleans, where we had people locked up and stuff.
And some of the biggest issues came up, and they were framing Bobby Seale and Ericka Huggins and all those people in New Haven.
I had to pick up and move to New Haven and work on those issues.
And so, you know, a lot of people didn't, wasn't public knowledge what I did, you know, and news paper written and all that stuff.
And it was fine with me, because I had my hands full, dodging the authorities and sad, stiff and traps that they might be setting for me, and moving and doing what I needed to do.
Can I ask a little bit more about that, about that particular period, when the party was really being targeted, and there was a lot of pressure on you, and you said you had people incarcerated, obviously.
So how are people dealing, how are you dealing with all of that?
Well, I like to think that I relied a great deal on people in the community, you know, because we had friends and all, and different places.
A lot of friends, they were, you know, public knowledge or anything like that.
We had people that would, you know, contribute money for bail and things of this nature.
And when I was in a community, and they needed more community support, I would engineer survival programs, if you would, help with free breakfast programs, help them set up a free clothing program in that community, and get people to contribute to those things.
And as a result, it began to get community support behind these incarcerated party members to try to get them out of jail and get them through the court system and get them free.
So it didn't tell a lot of different things, you know.
Was that high stress times for you? Just trying to stay one step ahead of the feds and all that.
Of course, but I didn't bother about that, because I, in doing what I did, I always sat step to obvious bullshit that would get you busted.
And then, you know, leave myself open to any of the chats that they laid, you know.
For instance, a new hearing, I got very little sleep because in the house, I would stay at, they would telephone all night long, which shit, like I've got a cash or weapons.
I got a dime from dynamite and all this shit, and I never responded to it, it was hanging up to telephone.
Because it was all in trapment, you know. And, you know, we began to know these things, and you just don't deal with them, you know.
And so, you know, I know people call and pretending to offer these things, so they're already in those places.
And, you know, I knew, they asked me, who was people, you know. I knew that.
So, I didn't accommodate any of it, you know.
You know, I just hang up the phone, leave it out the hood, get a couple hours sleep, and get up and start strategizing on what needed to be done.
You know, who I needed to see, who I needed to talk to, to matter of endless meeting with people, to explain crap, and explain what our programs were,
and what is shit supported, and stuff like that, you know. You just had to keep going.
So, since you, I wanted to ask you this question, since you were traveling around the country in this way,
are there certain, were there certain chapters of the party or certain places that most people don't know about that are, that are sort of dear to you or are interested that you'd like people to know about places where the Panther Party existed and did good work?
Well, I know there are a lot of different situations, you know, like down in Memphis, there was a group of young college kids that called themselves invaders.
I think they picked it up from some TV program or something, but they were trying to do something in the community, you know.
And so, you know, they heard about us and knew about us, and we got with them and sort of explained our programs to them, and things that suggested things that they should be doing and everything.
And they got with that program, and we eventually inducted them into it, and instead of the innovative, they became a chapter of the Black Panther Party.
So, it was a matter of communicating with people, you know, and giving little advice where needed or whatever, and learning what their ambitions were, what they contribute.
And making suggestions and so on, you know. So, you know, building an Augusta College solidarity, you know.
And communicating with, I'm going to say to the Latino community who were doing things in their community, and we forward solidarity with them, you know.
Well, as an anti-war moment, and all that, just a matter of becoming involved with anything that was oppressing people, you know.
And they're damn about the consequences of care, you know. Go to jail.
So, you go to jail and you use that equipment tool, because every time that I went to jail, I'm sitting on a bunk talking to people about the Black Panther Party, you know.
And explaining reasons, political reasons why they're sitting in jail.
So, when they got out of jail, they'd come around to the Black Panther Party office. And, you know, so you're never quit.
You know, we had people in prison, George Jackson, who got murdered because he was organizer of the prison system, Nationwide.
You know, still consider the hero by incarcerated prison around the country.
And so, we just never stopped. And that's why they wound up.
They couldn't brim us out. They couldn't get people to not support us and all that. So, it came right down to outright assassination and killings, to wipe us out, you know.
It was a whole campaign, but that was why, because we had die-hard determination that we were going to do whatever it took to free our community and deal with the problems of oppression.
You know, so, you know, it was quite a phenomenon.
You know, and some of the things that people don't know about it, and talk about it, it's all these young people that come to the party.
Some of them came with heavy issues from things that happened in their lives or didn't happen in their lives. And the Black Panther Party changed their perspective on things.
We changed them. We had people come in that had been to jail, been to prison. They had major issues. And we politically educated them and showed them how and why these things were happening. And as a result, they joined the party and the party to philosophy.
And some of them went to prison and stayed in there 40 years. And they never lost that perspective about what the party was all about.
And, you know, we took young people who were didn't have anything to do but hang out and get in the trouble. And we recruited them and taught them how to cook breakfast for children.
They wanted a gun to go out and kill somebody which said, no, no, no, no, no. You're coming in, you're going in there, some sisters in the kitchen and learn how to cook, get some eggs and get up and go and serve breakfast with the school children.
You go out when you're doing the middle of the day, you got nothing to do, you go out and try to get donations for these programs. Try to get people to donate clothing for our clothing program.
We gave them something to do and we changed their attitude and people don't realize that some of these kids, you know, we prevented them from crawling through their windows.
Now, how's it been taking their shit and instead of doing that, they had some progressive work to do. Some things to benefit the community. So people don't, you know, don't really have to call a bunch of tubs and crooks and just send that to the other.
But we changed people's attitude. We changed their agenda in light.
A lot of people had a lot of reasons to be angry. Yeah. They would come with this anger. Yeah. So we changed all out of that. We channeled that into something beneficial to the community.
And I think that was a major achievement and people don't realize that because we did not fill up the prisons with dog addicts and criminals. We didn't do that.
You know, we saved a lot of them from that fate by giving them something to do, giving them a place to live, providing food for them.
And when they pay off for doing that, was them going out into the community and doing stuff for people, you know, telling me, you know, you're living in a community, go down the street and see a lady grass and you cut it.
And don't take a dime for it. Don't take anything for it. Because, tell them, you see something come up and an issue come up where the Black Panther Party is supporting some program, go vote for it.
That would be payment enough for us. So as a result, people begin to understand what we're about and at the same time,
it calls the authorities to hate us more. You know.
So why were you so threatening to them, do you say, to the powers of B?
Because we've, first of all, exposed them. We can see 250,000 children free food every single day of the schools and session. Why can't the government do anything about it?
Well, if we can test people for sick of celinemia, which is a disease that they pretty much ignored. If we can establish free health clinics, well, people could go and be tested and engage in preventative medical care.
Why can't the government do it? Things like that, you know, is what calls them the haters. So, you know, just on and on all these survival programs, free education.
We started liberation school when people threw up their hands because their kids, they say, couldn't be educated and going to put out on the street and be candidate for going to jail or prison.
We had liberation school, we'd get them young and get them in and taught them relevant education, something that dealt with their reality and they were teaching them to read and stuff like that.
And at the same time, recruiting people who had the skills to teach, who were fed up with the bureaucracy of the educational system, who would come in and help us with the liberation school of the teachers' kids.
And we had some great successes, we got some kids running around now, who were very appreciative that they went to the Panther School. And so stuff like that, government, this government was very unsililized about it.
And the party was that you answered a call to or an invitation to come to Japan.
Yeah. Can you tell us a little bit about how that arose and what that turned out?
During that period, there were massive student rebellions and protests, and along with the anti-war movement and so forth.
We had some Japanese students who got wind of the party and what we were about and they wanted someone to come to Japan, you know, and they were very persistent.
And kept after us, finally the leadership said, I'm a big man, you're going and take Roberta with you.
So we took that long flight to Japan. And that's Roberta Alexander that you're going to.
Yeah. Yeah. And we got there and not speaking the language or anything.
And we hooked up with our name, you're speaking person that was living in Japan, who helped us a lot. But more than that, these people wanted us to speak to the student by the student protestors.
And I haven't seen so many people at a rally. And, you know, like I said, it was anti-war rally, railing against the enemy's war.
And, excuse me, and students over there, they had, I guess, a repressive system where, you know, the younger people were trying to break out of that.
And they were rebelling against, you know, their historical culture where you couldn't, you know, talk back to Eldridge Cleaver and, you know, they had no say".
And so they were breaking out the student for clothing down universities all over the place. And so we were, you know, introduced to some of the, I guess, more radical organizations and people.
And they, you know, had us go around to different provinces and, you know, meet people and attend these big gatherings and like that. And so, you know, Roberta and I, you know, we hung in there all at the same time being followed by,
I guess, Japanese version of the FBI, they were under the FBI's instructions to follow and, you know, keep tabs on us, I guess, you know.
And we know that they weren't slick as the American, you know, we'd be walking down the street and they'd be following us and they were, let's make a quick stop, turn around, stop, turn around. And these guys, I like they weren't following us. It was comical, you know.
But we had some fun with that. And, you know, and they followed us everywhere. And we went to a lot of different cities, you know. And, and it was, you know, an experience.
But we hooked up with Japanese film maker and they were to get his name Shinsuke Ogawa. He had a film company. He made, I guess, documentaries or whatever, you know. And he sponsored us going to different places.
And, you know, and it was an experience. I know, I guess we spent a month there on war. And, you know, it was something else. And of course, we were in all papers, you know.
And I do what they said. We're all over the place. And we were treated quite well. You know.
So, when time comes to leave, the World War II got to come home. But they told me you're going directly to sleep after that. So, I didn't.
They wanted me to go there and work with support committees that had developed. We had people that developed support committees in Denmark and Sweden.
And so, I went there and, you know, of course, they visited Paris and went into Germany and spoke with a lot of GIs that were serving there who had our paper and who knew about us and wanted to, you know, hear about what was going on.
And the country and wanted to know about, you know, the party and stuff like that. So, you know, we went to one base. I forget where it was. But anyway, in the city and the base commander, the zombie base knew we were coming.
And he blacked out the base, we were getting there in the evening at night. And the GIs had, you know, decided that they were going to host us with something.
And the base commander cut out all the power. No lights at all. So, I hear this, as we were standing out on the street talking around a corner, he had come to the formation of GIs.
And, you know, they say, well, the base commander heard you were coming and he called the blackout. So, if you don't mind, coming will go to this local village.
And, you know, we can sit down and talk because, you know, we want to talk to you. And so, we did that. And we went and talked most of the night. And they wanted to know who was going on in America. And what the black Panther Party was all about, you know, they got our paper and knew, you know, something about it.
And so, they wanted to know more. So, that was a really good experience, you know, to sit down and of course, we talked about, you know, our feelings about the war. And, you know, why should rebel against sitting, sitting, participating and so on.
So, that was, how are they feeling about things?
Oh, they were, you know, they were in accordance with what they had picked up from the black Panther Party. You know, matter of fact, they, you know, were forming some kind of organization of their own, you know.
In relation to that, and [which/that] didn't sit well with their command didn't sit well with their command and officer and so forth. But it was, you know, a great thing to see so far from home.
You know, and, you know, black G.I. had no good in the fight in the re-enemy. So, it was good to talk to them.
So, you served at this kind of an international ambassador for a while and then you headed back home?
Yeah, yeah. And I worked with those support committees and they said speaking engagements all over the place for schools and colleges and so forth.
So, you know, I spoke a lot to the meetings of exchange and the money wasn't that great, but, you know, they financed our travel and stuff while we were in there, area and so forth.
We stayed pretty busy going around to these colleges and universities and so forth and in Sweden and Denmark.
And I think we went up to Finland, I believe. It kept us pretty busy. And I know at one point, Bobby Seale, they got put in jail in New Haven.
He's been extradited to New Haven or whatever, but anyway, he was under the charge of murder, of Alex Rackley and they sent me a message. You need to come home right away, you know.
You need you once on the paper and also help, you know, organize and do something to save Bobbi or whatever, you know.
So, I was very anxious to get back home and I got wind of that, you know, what the hell, you know. And I came back and I had to move to New Haven and so I did them with all of that.
And were you there during that whole time that he and Ericka Huggins were in prison? Yeah, that was 14 months or 18 months.
And so we, you know, dealt with a lot of people, had a lot of people come in for support, you know.
Daniel Berrigan and Dr. Benjamin Spock and all people like that, we got to come to New Haven and had big rallies. I think I have a picture of some of it up there, maybe I don't know.
But anyway, we had to generate support and on a daily basis and people of New Haven were frightened of that.
And they thought things were going to explode. We said stuff like that for Sky's Olympic.
And they better not happen to Bobbi or New Haven being ashes, rhetoric.
Scared to hell out of them people in New England though.
And so, you know, we had people like Kingman Brewster, yeah, they said, you know, revolutionary, King, Ditto, Fried Trial, up here or whatever.
So, you know, the judges and courts" and Kurtz went through their routine under pressure from the FBI and the local law enforcement who they rule and so on.
And they thought that the best thing they could do was get rid of this clock, get rid of this, get it out of a nice, pristine New Haven community.
Or, for something bad happens and get Yale burned down.
So, I think that had a lot to do with the judges and courts"'s decision to get rid of this case because he didn't want to be responsible for any mayhem that might come about, you know, man.
So, after that, after New Haven, how much longer were you in the party?
Well, after the trial and everything, I was getting rid of it, I've come back to California and come home.
And I got a telephone call and some more crap. Attica Correctional Facility had exploded.
And the inmates had asked for the panthers to come up and negotiate the piece, the settlement or whatever of that.
And they told me Bobby Seale was coming, so don't go nowhere. I'll be coming through.
And we want you to go with him to Attica Correctional Facility. So, we went up to the prison, went through all of that and, you know, talked with attorneys that they were trying to do something.
And the prison warden and those people were hopeful that we would be able to quill it and all of that.
But as a result, Nelson Rockefeller wasn't having it.
And one thing that could have saved that explosion was for him to just show up or say he was going to show up.
And he, I guess he was getting rid of for re-election or something.
And he had a platform of being tough on crime and some crap like that.
And so he refused to come. He refused to talk to the inmates, so make any concessions.
And he, you know, pretty much hung the situation out the track.
And a lot of people lost their lives without, you know, needlessly. Didn't have to happen.
So we were there and I think after we went into the prison and listened to the inmates, the people that were occupying the yard and all of that.
And I think Bobby told them, well, you know, I need to go and confer with you and leadership of the party to see what we can do.
And you were able to go inside the prison during occupation.
And there was kind of a disheartening thing to walk out on the yard, you know, and people were like, hey, big man, you know.
And, you know, a few days later, people were dead, you know.
Just sit there, think of strong heart to deal with.
But anyways, you know, kill all those people.
And to see how pitiful the families of the guards were before, you know, before we went in, we were right there outside the prison.
These people, Megan, please, please do something.
You know, because my loved one is in there, you know.
And then when you go in there, you see these guards.
The prisoners had made the guards change clothes with them, you know.
And they're sitting out there on the yard in front of a fire.
And they're looking, you know, defeated and scared.
And, you know, you look at that sit and you know, you kind of take that away with you.
And then the next day, I was going to throw a game of the order to take back the prison.
And they just opened the kill of people like shooting chickens in a barrel or something, you know.
That's all kind of shit, man.
And there's proven later on that the guards didn't kill anybody.
And all these things that were propagated and put in the newspaper are.
So, anyway.
So you were dealing with a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
Where it would come up is.
Couldn't have ordered you to just jump with it, you know.
Trying to keep your sanity and keep your goal and your mind.
What you wanted to do.
What you needed to do.
You know.
Is that certain to where you are at that point or you're able to find reserves or start to think about moving on to something else?
You know, that was always something.
69.
You never knew what to expect and you know, you get the call and go here and say, and the other.
You just, I don't know, something in my personality just made me deal with it and get through it.
You know, there was a state of things.
I get a call from the, you know, the uprising of COINTELPRO.
We didn't know what it was called at that time.
But anyway, I get a call from New Haven, the good out in New York.
And since Sam Napier, they pure home.
And they didn't say what the hell it was about.
You know, since Sam Napier home, we talked about it.
And then they finally broke down and told me Sam Napier's been killed.
I don't know what Sam Napier, I don't know what to kill.
I know what Sam Napier's been with distribution.
New is favorite distribution manager for.
He had nothing to do with any military arm or party or anything.
So I go down there and we go about our office where it happened when he killed him and set the office on fire,
which was a pant and a distribution center.
They set it on fire and someone there took us to a hotel where told us that there were some ladies and a group of children scared to death.
Because this here was the beginning.
I didn't realize how strong this was, but between East Coast, West Coast.
And this is what this shit was all about.
And these ladies had these children didn't know if someone was coming and kill them or what.
And so we went to this hotel where they were held up.
And I told two comrades that we were with them and say, well, you know, first sort of been, you know, Sam Napier is in the morgue.
He's not going anywhere.
The first thing we need to do is find a safe place for these women and these children.
And so we made some calls and found a place where they would take them to.
It would be safe and all of that.
And as soon as we stepped out of that hotel, here's the cops everywhere screaming yelling like they do.
Guns drawn, you know.
And I backed up against the wall and I was able to pull out my gun and drop it behind me.
And they took us to jail.
They didn't take us directly to jail.
They put us in a paddy wagon.
And this was about, I don't know, two or three in the afternoon.
And they drove us around until about 10 or 11 o'clock at night before they took us to jail to, I guess, to hold us until, I don't know, until the lawyer stopped looking for us.
I guess I was. I'm pretty sure it was.
We were out of touch. We couldn't call anybody.
We wanted what the hell was going on.
Finally they took us and booked us into jail and into the Tombs, I guess it was.
And it took us from a local precinct to the Tombs.
And that's where we began our process of getting ready to charge us with something.
But anyway, they had us in jail for a couple of days.
And finally, the attorney finally found out what we were and came and told me, you know, what we had to appear before judge.
And we got a sympathetic assistant, you know, African American young lady.
And she said, well, you sit tight for a day or so.
A judge is going to be on the bench that I can talk to.
And, you know, we can see about what we can do.
And she knew that we were panthers, you know.
And so in the meantime, William Kunstler had located us.
And he came and told me that part of leadership told him to get me out.
And that I would deal with getting my comrades out and take care of that.
So that's what they did.
You know, we finally went to a judge and he said, well, told me, I'm going to dismiss the charges and let you go on the unconditioned, that you leave New York and never come back.
And I say, yeah, all right.
And my other fucking thing, he's just Roy Binging.
You can post me out of town.
So, anyway, I said, okay.
I got went back up to New Haven and started back working, what I was doing, what I was doing.
But anyway, it was some of the never-ending things.
In the time, meantime, I never needed to get to see Sam" Napier, but Pauline and his wife came down.
And she claimed the body and made a range of it to get him back out for you.
Just all kinds of stuff, man.
Unbelievable repression.
And during that period, the East Coast, West Coast thing was escalating due to the press and so on.
And somehow, the New York Panthers thought it was, let's see.
And they thought it was that Sam Napier had been killed by East Coast Panthers.
So Robert Webb, who was actually from the West Coast for working the East Coast,
was shining the head on the streets of New York as supposedly retaliation for Sam Napier.
So then the killing began.
There was sitting tent.
We love Sam Napier. I have a meant to work this horn as him, because he took control of the distribution of that paper early on.
And anytime, I could very Sam Napier, how many papers we got going to New York, and he would write all the exact number.
He would tell me who it sent them money in.
He was just a phenomenal guy that seemed like he came out of nowhere with those skills.
And he had put together a dynamite crew to help him in Skoglade.
And he said, stuff like, circle like to educate, get the papers out.
Yeah, yeah.
Great, great ways to let him.
So after all of this and handling all this, what did you do?
I was able to finally come back from the East Coast.
I pretty much worked out, I guess, out of central headquarters.
And let's begin to work on programs.
And the meantime, I had been selected by the president of Merritt College as an almost-boothed buzzman, they called it.
And I had to work with Mary.
He put me in charge of work study program to be able to run the budget on that, had a budget that I had to work with on that.
I had a lot of opportunities there to benefit the community.
So I knew that out at the center, the center of Edel, they had a system where in order to get out of person, the old, the bulls of parole.
And I said, well, that stinks. How are you going to get a job sitting in jail?
And I talked to Dr. Young Park, who was president, and who had hired me.
And I went to use some of the work study funds to provide education opportunities for some of these prisoners.
And he said, well, you know, all right.
I said, well, you know, I need somebody to help me with the adult authority to get them released.
So he went with me to sit down with the California adult authority, and we put the perspective to them that we would take on people on probation.
We would enter them into the college, and those that didn't have a high school diploma, we would get them into a work study program, and get them on a GED program.
And those that had some high school had finished high school, you know, if they wanted to pursue going to a four year college, we could enter them into a program, and they could work toward that.
And so it was, you know, an awful good refuse.
We set that up, and I had parolees coming to the school and enrolling in classes, and they knew it was pretty much a panther program, as I was in charge of it.
I told me, you know, you got to abide by your education requirements, and you're going to get a stipend every two weeks to help you live.
And we also have an on-campus food program where we got food meal tickets for you to eat twice, breakfast and lunch while you're on campus.
And in the meantime, you pursue your studies, you keep up with your attendance, and if we need you to work to help the library move something or move things around, you're going to help with that.
And that would be about the only type of labor that you have to do, you just maintain a program.
And so that worked pretty well for a while, you know.
And what killed the program was, we had an instructor's name was Felix Poindra.
I think her name was Felix Poindra.
And he was definitely a critic of the party, and he would say things in his classes, critical of the party.
And in the meantime, we had some panthers in those classes, and one day it kind of exploded, and they jumped up and knocked him under the ass in the classroom.
So, you know, that was a assault on a county employee, I guess you call it, so they got the Dr. Park and Dr. Park to me.
I can't save you on this one.
So, you know, that ended the program, but it was quite successful, for quite a while.
You know, so, the other things that, you know, I thought that was beneficial to the people in the community, and it would help these people that
would then deal to come out and contribute a little bit to their families, and have a viable program that took them somewhere.
So, anyway, they did things like that, you know.
They attended endless meetings dealing with endless programs, you know.
I remember having to go to a meeting with all these people in different forms of disability, people, you know, room for wheelchairs and stuff.
And I remember what the hell there was this, and once again something told me, keeping my set in your ears open and you learn something.
And so, these people were protesting, not being able to get the wheelchairs on sidewalks or get them into a federal or county buildings where they had a right to go and stuff.
And we talked and eventually come down to, you know, threatening to go out into the street with these wheelchairs and stop trackers.
So, protest that way. And as a result, we got sidewalk cut so people had ramps.
We got these ramps put on city buildings, and, you know, people don't know that that was Panther involvement.
But, just things like that, helping people organize rent strikes where they had pain on their walls and their housing, lead-based paint that make kids sick and stuff like that.
We had to organize rent strikes until landlord, if they didn't repaint these places and get rid of that stuff, that they wouldn't even get paid.
And so, you know, rent strikes caused some redevelopment there, and they painted, they complied with it.
But, you know, it took pressure to do it. And so, you know, just trying to meet the needs of the communities, what it was all about, you know, and, you know, things of this nature.
So, tremendous amount of work in different programs.
Yeah. You know, you did eventually decide to leave the park.
Yeah, well, that kind of happened.
You would do some political differences, I guess, you would call it, in that different things happen with UV.
I think Huey had a dislike for the organization as it were.
And, I never had been sadist, but he dispended all the chapters across the country.
And, I suppose, to bring organizers all into Oakland under the guys of having these people work on the Bobby Seale for Mayor campaign.
And, that was viable, but at the same time, I don't think he wanted to deal with the responsibility of a nationwide organization and all the things that needed, you know, had to be done.
So, in my opinion, he did a disservice to the people who had followed the Panther philosophy and had worked their tales off to develop programs, to gain resources to do that in their communities.
You know, all of a sudden you tell them to close down the chapters and the people in the community that benefited from what happened in those chapters.
So, that was one of my personal criticism of that move.
And, you know, then, of course, people begin to leave and all of that.
And, it got to a point, you know, even Bobby Seale left.
And, without any explanation, that's a wide, but, you know, it was all, you know, a result of due to ramifications of closing the party down, really, if you will.
And, it was a top decision, rank and file, and people like myself had never seen it.
And, I say, well, you know, Bobby Seale left and didn't say goodbye.
You know, it's over, for I'm certain it's over.
And, you know, I think it limped along a little while, where people out of the own self-angrant disment called party and called themselves as a chairman and a new leadership or whatever.
And, you know, Elaine Brown of GIF from Huey.
But, other than that, it was nothing. It was no party.
So, the people that were last minute hangers on who took advantage of what I guess financial resources, they were left over or whatever.
And, using the party's name, because it was out there, to do whatever they wanted to do.
I decided, you know, it's time to go. I fulfilled my mission.
And, you know, time to look for some other things and see if I have any other talents.
And, you know, small group of people came to me and told me, you know, in confidence that, you know, party's over and other people have taken it over.
And, if you want to leave the party, we'll follow you. We'll back you.
And, I said, well, nope. You know, some of the best organizers in this country.
So, you know, you just get out of, out of Oakland and go back to where you, wherever you want, because you have the talent to do whatever you want.
And, I know that. And, if you ever need me for anything, you know what a family.
And, we did that. And, I love.
And, you know, never look back.
Billy X Jennings kept after me for years to participate in reunions and stuff like that.
And, at any time, I went into retail. I got a job without anybody knowing my background. I got a job with Kmart as a citizen manager.
And, worked for them for about 13 years.
You went back to the, to the South?
Yeah. Yeah.
Got sent to some of the town in Virginia to train.
And, they moved you around quite a bit, you know, wherever that you needed.
And, so, I went through their training program and, you know, became successful at that.
And, it afforded me a lot, doing a lot of things that I think that I had done as a panther in terms of being a mentor to young people.
And, people come in and they're working for Kmart for a little or nothing.
And, they would have grievances against a supervisor and stuff like that.
You know, and I have to pull them aside and say, look, you need a job, you need money.
So, just hang in there and don't fly off and do anything that will damage you.
Keep this while you're got it because it's paying you something.
And, you know, I'm going to do what I can to help you.
And, you know, that's how, you know, developed, I think, some young people's character.
And, taught them how to do what was good for them and how to sidestep the snakes that were there to bite them.
And, like that.
And, I went from there, I got, I think I got tired of the place that Kmart sent me.
Yeah, I think it was real North Carolina, I think it was down there where I was crazy G.I.
And, I got a job with an outfit called, a retail outfit called, Service Merchandise.
And, it had a different merchandise and philosophy.
It wasn't so much great, big box stuff and dealing with a whole lot of little stuff.
It was mostly a place where you go and buy gifts.
You know, and I learned this system and went from, you know, I guess a trainee up until I got a point of storm and ran a couple of my own stores.
And, I find that they got to the point where they had different philosophy and their management and stuff like that.
It was pretty much like what's going on now.
You get up to a management where you're making a nice bucket too.
And, then they would fire you and use less person to get the job done.
And, the person at the top would get the damn big bonus, the money that you used to make.
And, so, you know, I gave that up and it was time where I would get close to being able to draw my social security.
So, I'll say, you know, I'm out of it.
Anyway, Billy kept after me, up after me.
And, you finally had one of his reunions in Washington, D.C.
And, I was living in Maryland at the time.
So, I decided to attend and all these old comrades, I thought you were dead.
And, stuff like that.
So, I began to realize, I guess, somewhat that I had a legacy going or whatever.
I began to relate to that and...
You hadn't talked about the Panthers in years, right?
No.
Nobody knew that.
None of those people in retail that I worked with, anything.
I never would have got the job.
Did your children know?
Did your family know?
Well, I guess five of me, your family.
No, I didn't tell them.
Because I had FBI agents go down and talk to my old aunt and try to figure out where I was.
Stuff like that.
And she said, well, I don't know.
And then I was in some story in Virginia.
A couple of suits came, called me.
Can we talk here outside?
We don't want to jeopardize or stop anything.
And then they're handing me a packet.
And there was something from the Freedom of Information Act from Washington.
It was a whole lot of shit that they had accumulated on me.
And it took a black matter of marker and marked out anything that I could suit her as for.
So I keep this on my archive.
And you know,
but then I had a kid too, and 1980, daughter.
And I kept myself under wraps from her because I knew that the government had no shame.
They would fuck with her to get to me if they could.
So seeing no anything about that until she was, I guess, 16 or 17 or something.
And that's when I finally relented and went to one of the reunions that Billy had kept after me to go to.
And it was in Washington, D.C.
And I was living in Maryland at the time.
So it was an easy place to get to and stuff.
And that's when I went on these people.
I know what happened here.
I thought you dead.
So full of things.
Now I'm here.
And you know, from then on, my daughter got up to age where none of this stuff would affect her.
Then I began to let her know about that.
You know, send her stuff, old stories, things like that.
So nobody could harm her about for anything that I'd done.
So it's kind of where that went.
I could just ask you know what it's been like now that you are telling your story and what you want to accomplish with it.
What kind of feedback you're getting from people.
Oh, I'm getting a tremendous amount of feedback because, you know, everywhere you go, you know, the legacy following here.
Pretty much.
And you're getting to have a deal with people and trying to address some of the same issues that you were addressing before.
That somehow, me, anyway, I can't help but become involved.
So I came back to California after I had moved around the South for a while and stuff.
And I reconnected with Carol, who's, you know, nurse.
I've been a nurse for years and years.
And anyway, I didn't know what it was, but some physical ailments.
It turned out to be prostate cancer.
So here in California, you know, I got the best treatment for that that I could get.
And, but anyways, I didn't think up here.
That was any kind of political repression that I found out very differently.
Because you had a combination of state troopers, county shares, and local police forces that were killing people.
And people were all up and armed about what to do about it.
So, you know, naturally I had to get involved in it.
And so we had big meetings and stuff like that.
And people were, you know, just really at the witch's end.
It's what to do about that.
And then we also had the immigration problem with the ICE and stuff.
So we began to get together with these people and try to iron out something that we could do.
And so we had big meetings and held some works out and so forth.
So out of the works out that I held, we came up with the idea of creating a help line for people who had no records
when they were abused by the cops and so forth.
And we called it the PACH.
And we established like a 24-hour telephone line where people can call and make a report.
And we would take that report and put it on the database.
And at some point people wanted to file a suit against police or whatever we could go to that database
and provide that information form to take the court or whatever.
And so that's still going.
And so, you know, there's always, you know, and there's issues that come up that to me you can't ignore.
I really upsetting as they killed 13-year-old Andy Lopez, cops shot him in the back.
He was walking his own neighborhood in the middle of the day, not bothering anybody.
And he had a toy weapon that this cop that sat him said it looked like an assault rifle.
But you can tell how acute carries heavy weapon as to a toy.
And so they opened up with him and all they did was shout at him.
And for the words, got out of their mouth.
They opened up and shouted for about seven or eight times and killed him.
So that became an age issue and created, you know, demonstrations and stuff.
And the bad part about it is that Sheriff Deputy was not indicted.
And he was put back on the job, put back on the street.
And, you know, that, you know, so it seemed like it never ended.
Since that happened, we had all these other killers.
You know, just endless names of, you know, scoring, re-rooting back to,
you know, for the reason they called this, called this the organ act, you know.
And, you know, so I, you know, involved as much as I can, we're not meant to, you know,
criticism, the DA and the county prosecutor and all those people give a voice to the people.
So the fight continues.
So it continues.
Absolutely.
You know, so, you know, I don't know, some of the people in the Civil Rights Movement could quit.
And I guess get wealthy, I get rich and find their peace and their heaven and that.
Not me, I'm not so blessed.
I got to keep fighting.
Well, we have to end there, I'm afraid.
So let me just say thank you.
Thank you for all of your work over the years.
And, uh, there's a horrible story now.
Talk about what's an important story.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.